Do you want Columbia University to be cursed by god of the Bible?
This is Republican Rick Allen.
Here we see him trying to use the fear of god
during his questioning of Columbia University President Minush Shafiq
about antisemitism on campus.
Christian nationalism is on the rise in American politics,
and on Wednesday, we saw him be a prime example of that.
Are you familiar with Genesis 12 3?
Probably not as well as you are a congressman.
Well, it's pretty clear.
It was a covenant that god made with Abraham.
That covenant was real clear.
If you bless Israel,
I will bless you.
If you curse Israel,
I will curse you.
And then in the New Testament,
it was confirmed that all nations would be blessed through you.
You. You do not know about that?
I have heard that.
Now that you've explained it, yes.
Do you consider that a serious issue?
I mean,
do you want Columbia University to be cursed by god of the Bible?
Definitely not.
Okay,
well, that's good.
So here. Here's the deal.
We got freedom of speech in this country,
of freedom of religion,
yet we also have Moses looking down on the entire body of Congress
who gave us the law.
Most of our laws were made and are supposed to be enforced
came from the original law.
And what we have today is a lawless land.
We have lawless universities
that are overrun by people who are threatening to
other Students
who are attacking other students
and creating fear in this country.
And we have a constitution that
requires us to treat other folks as we would like to be treated,
which is also in the New Testament.
Maybe you should have a course and,
you know, you don't have to believe it,
but, you know,
the Bible is an incredible book.
There's a lot of history there,
and you don't have to believe it,
but you need to know what's in there.
Maybe you should have a course suggested
for those who are having problems with all of this,
uh,
on the Bible and what's in the Bible and kind of what will happen if,
you know, under the wrath of god.
We have above the American flag in our chamber,
in God We Trust.
I mean, what god is that?
Do you understand why we're here?
This is a serious issue.
Young people are being indoctrinated by these professors
to believe this stuff,
and they have no idea that they're gonna be cursed by god,
the god of the Bible and the god over our flag.
Education is important.
Knowledge is important.
But the beginning of wisdom is the fear of god.
I yell back, the beginning of wisdom is the fear of god!
I speak for all non Christians and non believers.
Keep your god out of the fucking public square!
When people ask me why I criticize something I don't believe in,
here's why education is Important knowledge is important.
But the beginning of wisdom is the fear of god.
Dictating to us that we must fear your god
is an authoritarian approach
to forcing your dogmatic belief system under the rest of us.
Handmaiden's Tale,
here we come! These people need to be voted out of office!
I yell back, stay falling, heathens!